writing the surge in demand for AI and
ml professionals is evident as companies
strive to build AI powered products
develop intelligent systems and leverage
productive analytics the growth of AI
and ml is driving potential to
revolutionize Industries create new
opportunities and address complex
challenges as businesses recognize the
transformative impact of AI and ml the
demand for skilled Ai and ml
professionals will only continue to rise
the global AI Market is projected to
grow at a cage year of 36.62 percent
from 2020 to 2025 offering 69 millions
of job opportunities therefore the
demand for a and ml professionals is
surging with AI specialist roles
experiencing a 74 annual growth rate
making it one of the fastest growing job
categories according to LinkedIn
positions such as AI Engineers ml
researchers data scientists are high in
demand there are many more exciting
career opportunities in Ai and ml
including ml engineering AI product
manager robotics engineering AIR
research scientist and many more now as
an aim and engineer you can expect to
earn a competitive salary according to
Glassdoor the average annual salary for
AI and ml engineers in the United States
is around one ten thousand dollars
however it is 10 lakhs per annum in
India so if you're fascinated by Ai and
ML and desire a rewarding package that
fuels your Ambitions then take up this
professional certificate course in Ai
and machine learning design in
collaboration with IIT kanpur which will
Empower you with highly sought after
skills in ml deep learning reinforcement
learning NLP generative ai explainable
ai chat GPT and much more again a
Competitive Edge in the AI field through
expert and master classes by IIT
Campbell faculty live sessions with
industry experts and engaging Hands-On
projects stay at the Forefront of AI
advancements with this program simple
learn courses have enabled Learners to
achieve successful career transitions
accelerate career growth and secure
salary increases this professional
certificate course covers generative AI
chat GPT gbt models and explainable AI
opening those to Limitless possibilities
first Kickstart your AI and a machine
Learning Journey Through This
introductory session
the next course covered in this
professional certificate program is
apply data science with python you will
understand Python and its applications
in data science discover the shl tools
and techniques that are vital for your
role in machine learning course as
python is an indispensable component of
data science acquiring this knowledge
will undoubtedly elevate your career
prospects next machine learning this
comprehensive a and machine learning
certification covers all critical
aspects of machine learning including
supervised learning unsupervised
learning practical modeling and
algorithm development followed by that
we have a deep learning with Keras and
tensorflow you will learn care as
tensorflow and advanced modeling
techniques from this course to build a
successful career later we have advanced
deep learning and computer vision to
excel in machine learning it's crucial
to grasp the concepts of deep learning
this Advanced course Dives deeper into
computer vision Basics opencv Keras and
tensorflow 2 pi touch computer vision
for OCR and object detection providing
the necessary skills for a successful
carrier and finally we have a caption
project as part of this a and machine
learning certification you will
undertake a caption project where you
can apply the skills you have acquired
throughout this program to tackle a real
world problem relevant to the industry
so what else can you expect from this
program this a and ml certification
course will cover skills like statistics
python chat GPT generative AI NLP deep
learning chat bot and many more along
with that you'll also get hands-on
experience with the latest tools and
techniques this program will also cover
the industry projects like social media
e-commerce manufacturing edtech
Healthcare and many more exciting
projects by choosing this certification
course you could land a job with
prestigious companies like Microsoft
Amazon Cisco Google IBM apple and many
more this program has benefited many
aspiring a and ml engineers and
professionals who have already enrolled
and earned their certifications you can
check out their positive feedback on the
course page the link to which is added
in the description box below so if you
are looking to purse your career as an
AIML engineer and acquire skills that
will prepare you for your job consider
enrolling in this intensive
certification program starting May 29
2023. we are thrilled to announce that
we have some fantastic cohorts coming up
we are dedicated to accessibility
offering financing options to make our
program affordable and budget friendly
choices for you the course price is just
1 lakh 53 400 making it an attractive
investment you can learn more about this
course by clicking the link in the
description box below if you have any
queries regarding the professional
certified course in Ai and machine
learning or need any help then please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be happy to
resolve all your queries at the early
list until next time thank you stay safe
and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here